well welcome everyone so next up we have
estern am speaking on one weird trick to
becoming a better software developer
let's help welcome her all right thank
you all for coming I'm here because I
would like to be a great developer
someday I've been a software developer
now for about seven years and in my
relatively short career I've worked at a
number of companies and between work the
SoCal Python meetup I helped to run and
coming to conferences like PyCon I've
had the good fortune of knowing at least
a few developers whom I consider great
I've been trying to figure out what they
have in common because I don't believe
that developer greatness is a fixed
trait I take the growth mindset and
believe that by working hard and
practicing the right habits I too can
achieve greatness but what exactly do I
mean by a great developer I'll explain
by way of a few illustrations me goofus
goofus is a developer who's been working
at Acme widget co for six months she
nailed her whiteboard interview with the
most elegantly written algorithms the
team had ever seen her first project
involved building a slingshot prediction
machine and she was excited because she
felt something similar at her previous
job so she knew exactly how the machine
should be designed goofus worked really
hard for two weeks but when she was
finished the product manager found that
goofus had made some assumptions about
the specs that weren't quite correct
goofus worked hard with that complaint
to make every change but but the project
ended up taking several weeks longer
than expected goofus has a co-worker
named gallant gallant has been working
at Acme for only a little longer than
goofus has but Gareth already has a
process in place for new projects she
sets up a very short daily meeting with
the designer and QA lead so that they
can give and receive feedback on
features and change requests right away
one day gallant went to lunch with the
company's marketing analysts who
mentioned that a part the Galant was
building could be useful for another
company
project by adding some tracking Galant
found she could easily add tracking
within the current project scope and
this offhand feature request ended up
doubling Acme widget companies revenue
for the year a final story goofus was
tasked with developing an internal tool
leading to junior developers on the
project goofus was excited at the chance
to teach the newbies how to code a
smallish eated and designed a framework
that was really elegant and efficient
however the junior developers had
trouble even setting up their
development environments in a way that
let them start working on the project
soon the junior developers stopped going
to goofus with more of their dumb
questions instead they started going to
gallant for help because goofus had been
too busy with optimizations and test
cases to write any docs gallant had a
message goofus constantly for more
clarification on the architecture both
senior developers ended up spending way
too much time helping the junior
developers on the project and the
delivery date went further past the
original deadline and even worse gallant
had trouble meeting her own deadline on
her own project because she'd been so
busy helping out the others these
stories are greatly exaggerated but I
bet most of you have seen or experienced
similar situations in your own jobs what
are the qualities of developers like
gallant that set them apart from
developers like goofus well most of us
tend to think first of technical ability
when it comes to developer greatness
this is from stack overflows annual
survey with responses from around 64,000
developers in 2017 it can't be denied
great developers must have a solid
foundation of technical skills also
great developers ship the right project
at the right time often the emphasis is
on the on-time part but the right
product is just as important there's no
point in writing software with perfect
code and 100% test coverage if nobody
ends up using the darn thing now you may
or may not find the top trait surprising
and one metric that's not on here that I
always come back to is if I worked with
someone like gallant and they told me
they were leaving the company
would I consider following them how many
of the other developers would feel the
same way why do we want to work with
great developers well they make good
software they help us become better
developers because we learned so much
from them they make our jobs easier
maybe even more fun we software
developers usually work as part of a
team so thinking about the QA person
testing our software or the DevOps
person helping us package up our code to
deploy to prod or the product manager
who wants to show off cool new features
to the company clients if we code with
their needs in mind will be the
developer everyone wants to work with
and it turns out empathy skills are what
helped great developers be so great so
let's talk about this one weird thing
called empathy first let's make sure we
all understand what empathy is here's a
simple definition that I like empathy is
the experience of understanding another
person's condition from their
perspective you place yourself in their
shoes and feel what they are feeling
empathy is marked by a distinction
between oneself and another there are
two types of empathy one is emotional
empathy which is not just about feeling
compassion or being nice for example if
your coworker is upset because they're
hungry and this meeting you're all in is
running late you may feel sorry for them
that's sympathy but if you feel their
hunger or you remember yourself being
hungry in long meetings and it moves you
to take action to help your coworker
maybe you'll sneak them a snack or
suggest out loud that we cut the meeting
a little short you're feeling empathy
there's also cognitive empathy which is
the ability to understand something from
the perspective of another cognitive
empathy is tied to the concept of theory
of mind which is the understanding that
others have mental states that differ
from one's own and it's not just enough
to imagine yourself in other shoes
because what if your assumptions about
the other's perspective are all wrong to
use a trivial example you are a slack
power user so whenever you need to ask a
co
or something or to give them a heads up
about some kind of change you fire up
slack and you shoot them a message and
you go your merry way but if you really
wanted to make sure your coworker got
your message
you might take us take a second to check
first does this co-worker you slack the
way I do or do they prefer email or even
a face-to-face interaction assuming they
would want what you yourself prefer
would not be the most emphatic choice
you should instead make an effort to
learn what their preference actually is
if you don't truly take another's
perspective what you're really doing is
called projection rather than empathy
you've heard the golden rule do to
others what you'd have them do you but
the golden rule isn't about what you do
putting yourself in someone else's shoes
means fully imagining yourself as that
person you treat them as they want to be
treated rather than the way you yourself
would like to be treated
while the two types of empathy are
related to each other
cognitive empathy activates different
areas of the brain from emotional
empathy a deficit in one doesn't
necessarily mean a deficit in the other
regardless empathy isn't easy for most
of us it requires effort a lot of
patience and a certain imaginative
ability for us to place ourselves in
somebody else's shoes especially if the
other person is dissimilar or unfamiliar
to us yet empathy is often seen as
merely a soft skill we tend to
undervalue soft skills in tech and so
you may believe for this reason or
another that empathy is not worth the
effort to practice but I don't think
that's true if our brains can learn how
to write complex algorithms or cook up
layer upon layer of abstraction over a
set of arbitrary business rules
why couldn't we also learn to get better
at seeing what others see or feeling
what they feel to do our jobs better
also research has shown that soft skills
are surprisingly important for building
productive successful teams Microsoft
recently released a paper entitled what
makes a great software engineer they
claimed to have identified 53 attributes
of great developers but awfully provide
a much shorter summary which I'm going
to quote here
there's a lot of good stuff but what I
want to emphasize is the last bit the
part in red which I mentioned resonates
with me so how do we practice empathy to
get better at understanding how others
think and feel I've got five ideas for
leaving mostly to cognitive empathy they
may not all work out for every one of
you but I hope everyone finds that at
least one of the suggestions works for
them I'm going to start by suggesting
one baby step where the other and the
self other distinction I described
earlier is actually still you so how
many of you have looked at some code
that you found absolutely unreadable
you ran get blame and discovered that
the terrible coder was in fact yourself
this is code you'd written a year ago
but it's almost as though somebody else
entirely had written it someone stupider
the problem is not that passed you was
actually stupid it's because past you
had a completely different set of
knowledge assumptions and context from
which they were working so going the
other way when current you writes code
or documentation take a few minutes to
consider this well future you who has a
completely different immediate context
and working knowledge be able to
understand or follow your code when you
see it again one of the best ways to
practice this is when you're adding
logging to your code let's say we have a
function and it handles a request and
you've already thought through the ways
in which you could break so you have
this exception handler but imagine how
future you so that's you a year from now
with no memory of writing this function
or what it does or or why how would you
understand a log message that looked
like this it's not that helpful what in
future you appreciate some hints as to
why this function might have failed or
what the parameters even mean think
about what information future you would
need to be able to trace and debug the
issue as quickly as possible let's add
some more verbose logging some better
error handling and messaging now when
you see this log the stack trace you've
got actionable data the same goes for
documentation thinking of future you may
help you write better Docs
when I deploy a project or handle an
incident or even run a so-called
one-time script I open up a text file
and write down one line for every step
that I just took so that the next time I
have to do this I don't have to remember
or relearn everything that needs to be
done or its context I almost always find
myself the next time I do this
deployment thanking past me so thinking
of future you as someone else you can
empathize with is one baby-step way to
practice getting better at empathy and
in so doing you will become a better
software developer but guess what you
can't practice empathy all by yourself
empathy is by necessity a social
reaction so you depend on others to
practice it one step further than trying
to put yourself in your own shoes would
be to try to put yourself in another's
shoes and since it's easier to feel
empathy for someone who is more similar
to you if you really want to level up on
your empathy skills you should try the
following during your next project or
even for just a day make time to learn
the job of a co-worker who is not a
fellow developer maybe join the QA team
or the dev ops team to see the kinds of
issues they face on their side of this
project you're all working on this will
benefit you in several ways first off
the more you work with someone the more
familiar they'll become to you and the
easier it'll be for you to start seeing
what they see feeling more empathy for
them you'll notice how the code you
write affects those who are required to
test your code or to make sure the
server list functions in the cloud
running your code
don't error out with mysterious bugs
that wake people up at 3:00 in the
morning so then maybe you'll be more
conscientious about updating the
dependency list and the package you're
about to deploy to prod or maybe you'll
find in handle more edge cases because
you'll have thought to ask the QA team
what those might be before they get to
work testing them in the best case
scenario you'll ship your project more
quickly because you'll have shortened
the feedback and iteration cycle that
you need to finish the product as a
bonus you'll become more familiar to
your co-workers and it's more likely
they'll come to feel more empathy for
you
to generalize even further you can
improve your empathy skills by
exercising something all the great
developers I know have in spades which
is curiosity not just about other people
but about new projects ideas and
experiences the great developers I know
constantly seek new things to try or
novel ways to tackle a problem we all
naturally gather tons of experience as
we progress through our careers but
seeking out different kinds of
experiences and exploring new ideas will
accelerate your progress exponentially
because you can integrate your
experience with a bunch of new
perspectives you also gain a wider view
of the systems you build and work in as
a whole and in some cases by better
understanding the problem and seeing a
more complete picture you might find
that the best solution is actually to
solve a completely different problem
altogether some companies like Google
already know the benefits of having
engineers try on other hats they have
programs that let people do just that
but even if you don't work at Google
that doesn't mean you can't sit down
next to a co-worker to shadow them for a
day or even just have lunch with someone
just to get to know them a little better
speaking of new experiences another way
to improve your empathy for other
developers and your users is to read
code written by others you want to do
this any way to deepen your
understanding of the libraries or
languages you work with but another
benefit is that you observe the great
variety of ways a given problem might be
solved you might have an inkling of this
from whenever you search the Python
packaging index for a library to use one
very simplified comparison if you work
in Python and you want to store and
retrieve data from a relational database
you'll come across the Django or M and
sequel alchemy both libraries allow you
to access data from a database but one
creates almost a direct one-to-one
mapping between an object and a row from
a database table using the active record
pattern while the other separates logic
having to do with objects from the logic
underpinning database operations using
the unit of work pattern if you look
into these and the many other solutions
that exist they'll show you how the
author of each library chose to make
sense of this
problem of data persistence maybe it'll
present for you a new perspective that
will help you find the right solution
for your own problem or maybe you'll
notice shared patterns in the waste
solutions are written by multiple
developers and you'll understand why
these patterns exist in both Django or M
and C Galaga me retrieving the number of
all the rows in the table is a method
call named count which is a lot like
what you write in raw sequel so that
would require less mental overhead for
developers who are trying to learn
either library and that's what the
famous principle of least astonishment
is about when designing a component it
should behave that way users expect it
to behave well to know how users might
expect a component to behave you need
first to figure out who the users are
and then you need to see your component
through their eyes building an interface
in general is a really good exercise of
cognitive empathy when you write an API
you need to consider who is a typical
user of this API one of the most common
arguments that users will send over when
they call your method will in what order
are they likely they son them in other
words what are your functions
dependencies are there common default
values for some of these arguments when
the user calls your endpoint what do you
think they'll expect to get back from it
what return type a response
I find tests really useful for figuring
out how to build these layers of
abstraction because your test cases are
really just instances of a client using
your function or your library let's say
you have a brilliant new startup idea
it's OK Cupid for dogs so neat for your
clients and you to write a function to
find a dog so we have our test case and
let's think about how we want this
function called find dogs to work by
writing a test for it
so we most likely want to find a pet by
relationship status and we expect a JSON
object with a list of dogs that match
that status so that means we want our
function to get us a list of dogs and to
do this it needs to make an API call and
now you have this function but probably
to call this API you need some kind of
authentication right so we're gonna add
some username and password parameters
and of course now we have to change
test to add the same things okay so now
you have this function and it gets you a
list of dogs but looking at this find
dogs function again doesn't that look
kind of weird
why does a function that's supposed to
just find us some dogs need to know
anything about a username or password
that's a hint that we should separate
these bits out but even if we find that
find dogs should not accept a username
and password specifically as parameters
the find dogs function does need access
to them somehow in other words this
username password authentication bit is
a dependency of find dogs
maybe we can encapsulate this username
and password implementation into some
sort of class like the dog API object
let's call it and find ox can now call
this API object going back to our tests
we now can fix our params but you know
to be honest that looks a little strange
still again if I'm looking at a function
called find dogs I don't expect to need
to pass in any kind of off dog thing
right but what if I made a very small
change so instead of this I could do
something like this and then maybe have
a clearer name for it now this to me is
a user of this API client it looks
familiar and it makes sense to me
I hope I still feel this way your future
me still feels the same way a year for
now but with find dogs encapsulated this
different way I can see this component
for what it is which is an API client to
get dogs and that's what the client
looks like Malta evil a developer who
wrote a JavaScript framework that powers
Google photos Google+ Google Drive and
some other very obscure tiny websites
set this at a recent talk he gave at J's
con Faust raelia the way we talk about
myself as a senior engineer is that I'd
say I know how I would solve this
problem the next level is that I can say
I know how others would solve this
problem what this means and this is
Malta's conclusion as well is that it
takes both experience and empathy to
create the right kinds of abstractions
for your application now you saw how
cognitive
empathy helps with naming things which
is one of the famous hardest problems in
computer science clear specific and
descriptive names make code more
readable to other developers and at
certain scales it's more important to
write understandable code than it is to
write performant code consider that a
bug in your code may cost the company
hundreds of dollars a month but if it
takes to developers one extra week to
debug the problem because they had so
much trouble understanding the code or
what it did that's thousands of dollars
more similarly an optimization you write
for your program might save you
thousands of dollars a year in CPU
cycles saved but if the code makes it
risky to introduce changes then those
cost savings might just be wiped out by
the development time required and the
missed opportunities so software must be
written not just for the computer
executing your instructions but also for
the humans who need to maintain or
change your code programming is really
another form of communication which is
why cognitive empathy will help you
become better at it another reason why
empathy is crucial to effective
communication is that it lets you
establish grounding not to get too
technical but grounding is sort of the
TCP handshake of human communication
it's a set of mutual assumptions
knowledge and police that get
coordinated between you and the person
you're talking to to ensure both of you
are on the same page establishing
grounding can be as simple as nodding
while you're listening to someone to
signal that you follow what they're
saying or making a quick request for a
clarification like huh most of us
already practice grounding in everyday
conversation but one way to get better
at grounding is to teach something to
someone else imagine how you would
explain to a three-year-old why
dinosaurs don't exist anymore now
imagine how you'd explain the same thing
to a 23 year old we intuitively know
that for a young child we might need to
describe things more simply and at a
higher level than for an adult but it
requires more effort for us to do this
well when wearing among adults we all
know someone who claims to love teaching
but assumes we have base knowledge about
the topic that we don't this person will
explain things in a way that goes
over our heads or that's effectively
meaningless to us or on the other hand
they'll assume we know too little and
waste a lot of time teaching us things
that we already know all they had to do
was spend just a few minutes to check
first that they understand what we
actually knew in order to do a much
better job of teaching us something
relevant and understandable but even if
teaching is not your thing you can still
practice grounding beyond everyday
conversation let's say you're in a
product meeting to go over some
requirements when it ends take a few
extra minutes to ask the other people in
the meeting to describe the main
takeaways from their points of view if
they are main takeaways are different
from yours then you clearly require more
grounding the more you communicate or
even over communicate the more knowledge
and context still share and a more
cognitive empathy you'll share in fact
it's been theorized that empathy evolved
for exactly this purpose to improve
coordination between members of the
group so that they can respond more
effectively to potential opportunities
or threats context is also important
because decisions are made under
constraints and sometimes we rush to
judgment on decisions without seeing the
bigger picture so it's important to ask
questions to fill in that context great
developers don't hesitate to ask
questions even if it means admitting
they don't know something and one
question that's very effective at
gathering context is why why did you
pick this library over other libraries
that might do the same thing why do we
need to collect user data in this manner
if there's an alternate way to get the
same data why do you want this button to
go here instead of over there now why is
an easy enough question to ask but the
hard part is actually listening to the
answer if you have a preconceived idea
of what the other person is about to say
you might not actually listen to the
answer because you're busy thinking up a
response of your own you'll talk right
past each other active listening is
making a conscious effort to give your
full attention to the person speaking so
that you hear and understand the
complete message being conveyed
listening is especially difficult if
you're feeling angry or defensive
so it's especially important to practice
active listening when you're feeling
negative emotions for example if you
hear criticism in a code review one
thing you could practice is active
listening don't respond to the comment
right away first stay silent suspend
your judgment temporarily gather more
information before responding by
paraphrasing or asking follow-up
questions to demonstrate you fully
understand the other person's argument
there's a rule in communication theory
called Miller's law and it's this to
understand what another person is saying
you must assume that it is true and try
to imagine what it could be true of
let's say a developer comes up to tell
you that a library that you wrote is
broken now this might make you upset and
maybe you could ask them why do you
think my library sucks but that puts
them on the defensive you're questioning
the premise implying the problem is with
them alternatively you might stop and
think okay assume my library is broken
this person can't do their job what are
our options
you might ask some clarification
questions what are you using this API
for what is it lacking that you need
could there be another way to get you
what you need
I was holding judgment you're showing
that you're on their side and by asking
clarification questions you're more
likely to gain context for what they're
actually trying to do this is the goal
of active listening and it'll lead to
you're having more empathy for the
person you're talking to a friend of
mine once asked me do you know what you
call someone who's always complaining
about existing code being terrible all
the time and the answer was junior I
think of this often I remember earlier
in my career when I would see something
that we might derisively call legacy
code and I would judge whoever wrote it
as maybe not being not that good at
writing code I'd spend a lot of time
trying to refactor it but what I didn't
do so well was to invest time in
understanding the code to see why it
might have been written the way it was
we could apply a version of miller's law
to legacy code when i find code that
works but is unreadable to me I first
imagined that the developer who wrote it
must have started out with good
intention
and clear designs I try to see what
sorts of constraints existed that maybe
haven't been documented so I can't see
them or what edge cases I haven't
encountered that this code might be
addressing in other words just because I
couldn't easily understand the code
doesn't mean that the code is bad or
that the developer who wrote it was dumb
now to be clear if the code is broken or
buggy judge away but if the codes
already in prod and it works giving it
the benefit of the doubt will help you
resist the urge to refactor
which is good because your factors can
become very difficult and costly I can
tell you to sum it up the purpose of
developing software is to create things
that other people want to use the best
software developers excel at this for
several reasons they understand what
their users want they write code
efficiently and ship it on time and they
make it easier for those with whom they
work to do their own job as well so that
the whole team can deliver a quality
product I hope I've convinced you that
empathy is important for all of these
and a worthwhile thing to practice and
hear inconvenient list form are the five
exercises to help us become better at
empathy I hope this will help you to
write better software work better in
teams and give your career trajectory a
boost I would love to hear what you have
to say not in a Q&A but outside in the
hallway or on Twitter you're free to
contact me by email as well
my flights are posted on that link and I
want to thank a bunch of people who
helped me to write this talk in one way
or another so here they are and of
course I want to thank the whole Python
community and I want to thank you all
for coming to my talk
[Applause]
[Music]